there's this giant mess like you said
the difference between the
simulator and real life also gets at
that somehow that there is uh
somehow the the fear of death all of
that
beautiful mess comes into play is there
a comment you can make on
commercial flight like with sully
landing uh that plane famously
uh versus the simulator all of those
discussions is there some
well it's it's very it's very similar to
what i was talking about earlier with
the a6 so
one is when you're flying with a crew uh
their standardization
so you gotta remember when sully flew
when his first officer that's the
co-pilot
showed up you know first time they'd met
and this happens all the time in the
commercial world you know there's
six seven thousand pilots at united
airlines you know your chance of flying
with the same guy all the time is slim
and none we're in the navy
we were crude so i had a primary and a
secondary
wizzo that flew with me for a while for
months
oh oh yeah for like all of the
deployment so because you wanna
use you have to trust all of those
things
it increases the capability airplane
it's not to say we can't swap out
but for true effectiveness especially in
very complex missions like
a forward air controller we're in the
air actually controlling ground assets
and supporting ground troops
if you're in a high threat area which is
crazy busy
you have to you have to be melded when
you do that you have to have trained to
do that job otherwise you're going to be
ineffective
so when you get to the commercial world
and i've got tons of friends at fly
commercial
there is a standardization like we know
that
at this point i'm going to put this
switch you're going to do that and
everyone they know their rules
captain's going to do this first
officer's going to do this and they know
that when the emergency breaks out so in
sully's case
when they take the birds and they know
they've got a problem and if you've
listened to the cockpit recordings of
him the two of them talking
you know you gotta remember they're
talking to each other when you hear the
full tapes but they're also talking to
the air traffic controllers in the new
york area
and it's like we got a bird strike and
the first officer already knows hey
silence the alarm they silence the alarm
the first officer is pulling out the
book he's going through the procedures
while sully's actually flying the
airplane knowing that they've lost their
motors and
you got to think of his decision process
like they're trying to get him to go
into an airport into new jersey
and he realizes not happening we're
going to put this thing and he made a
decision soon enough
so that he could prepare everyone on the
airplane that he was going to put this
thing in the hudson river
and he did it flawlessly i mean every
single person walked away from that
wreck the only thing that didn't survive
was the airplane you know and it got
fished out of the hudson but
um what is it about those human
decisions he had to make
is that something you put into words or
is that just
deep down some instinct that you develop
as a pilot over time it's when we
when you train uh you know an aviation
is a self-cleaning oven so if you make
bad decisions
you're you're and the list is long and
distinguished of those who have died by
making bad decisions oh man
um so when you look at what he did or
the way we train because the the
commercial industry
and the navy and the air force for all
that we have what's called we have
emergency procedures
that we have to know like engines on
fire the first three steps you just have
to know what they are
right so they know the airline uh same
type you know they go hey i know this is
they pull the book out because the
airplanes are designed they're built to
have some time
but there's a point where you have to
make a decision and you can't
second-guess it so when he decided i'm
putting this in the hudson river
he couldn't all of a sudden halfway
through it go well maybe i can get over
to that airport
he he looked he made a quick assessment
this is that 80
solution where you go these are not i'm
you know it's like a multiple choice
test when you go oh my god i don't
really know the answer but i know a
and d are wrong yeah gone so the jersey
airport and going back to laguardia
gone yeah so what's my next option well
the hudson river's there
and that's probably looking pretty good
or what is my other one can i get a
restart on the
the motors and then if i can get a
restart now can i take it someplace else
he had to make really really fast
decisions and then once they
as they they go that 80 solution you
realize all right i'm going into the
hudson
there's the 80 get the book out let's
see if we can get an error start because
if you listen to the tapes they're
trying to get
air started the closer he gets to the
water
the more he's going i'm ditching the
airplane so
the original decision to this is my best
option right now
this is where i'm going and you start
eliminating anything that could possibly
change the events
which they tried to do and then he gets
to that last minute says we're going in
the water
they change the plan they secure the
airplane they do exactly what they do
and he does that basically flawless
landing on the
on the hudson but you got to remember
every s it's every six months for
commercial they go
back and they do research in the
airplane in the simulator where they
train to
the airplane being broken you just lost
a motor you just lost another motor
so they go through this extensive
training you know
and all these and it's you know you know
we used to refer to it in the navy as
the pain cave where you're gonna get in
because you know
that when you get in for your check ride
in a simulator that the airplane is
going to break
you're going to lose hydra and it's
sometimes they're a problem like oh i
just lost this hydraulic system but i'm
having an issue on the other motor well
if i shut down this motor
and i've got a hydraulics you know
because there's two hydraulic systems
one on each motor
well if i've got an issue with the left
motor hydraulic system and my right
motor is starting to give me indications
do i want to shut the right motor down
because that's going to kill my
hydraulic system that's good
and now i'm flying on a good motor with
a bad hydraulic system and without
hydraulics the airplane won't fly so
they
it's a really they're challenging
problems that you have to think through
in real
time and of course the weather's never
good it's always dark
it's always crappy you're going to break
out it i mean it's just all this stuff
gets compiled on top of you
and it's intended to increase the level
of stress
because when things happen like in
sully's case
we like to joke it's going to stem power
you know where the functional part of
your brain shuts down and you are
literally on instinct like an animal
well if you've trained so much that that
is the instinctive reaction that you're
going to have
when the main part of your your your
cognitive abilities start to shut down
you're you're running that instinct is
ingrained so much into you that you know
exactly what to do
and that's literally how it happens so
there's no
how do i put it fear of death like in
sully's case
do you think he was at all ever thinking
about the fact
if his decision is wrong a lot of people
are going to die
you know i can't speak for him but i
would say there was so much going on in
the cockpit in that time
his his mindset was probably
i can do this i'm trained i'm going to
do the procedures
i've practiced this before i've done
these things and you know i'm assuming
that in his mindset because i never
thought about when things were really
bad you know if you're having problems
with the airplane that
you know that i was going to mort you
know and and planted into the ground it
was always
you know maybe it's an ego thing where
you think i can do this
you